If you are adventurous and don't suffer from vertigo, how about having "Dinner in the Sky" with a panoramic view?
You can have this wonderful experience in a restaurant in Belgium.
This novelty restaurant uses a crane to lift guests, waiting staff, tables and chairs into the air.
Forbes Magazine has included it in their list of the world's ten most unusual restaurants.
The total concept like catering, entertainment, decoration and location can be adapted to customers' needs.
There are 22 seats in comfortable leather chairs and 5 people may operate in the central aisle of the table,...
...such as cooks and entertainers.
The table weighs 5 tons and is hoisted on 16 steel cable ropes by a 100 ton crane into the sky.
A professional team of event managers and technicians attends every event.
This concept transforms dining into a magical moment,...
...which is guaranteed to leave an everlasting impression.